Furious 7 you know what's more
surprising than the fact that there's
seven of these the fact that they
actually got better up until Fast Five I
wasn't a huge fan but that film
reinvigorated this franchise and I had a
lot of fun with fast six as well I
thought they were both very well
directed action movies James Wan who is
really well known for the conjuring and
the insidious films and the first Saw
movie is now taking over the directorial
reins and since I try to avoid spoilers
because I care about your experience at
the theater I won't explain the revenge
plot that's going on in this film in
case you have not seen the last one but
essentially a character is no longer
around and we have the team we know and
love led by Vin Diesel going out for
revenge against the guy responsible I
bought this blu-ray collection even
though I like about half of the movies
and largely because they come in a tire
it's a freaking tire of blu-rays can you
get more awesome than that my point is I
like having fun at the movies so I was
excited for Furious 7 and I can report
that it is a lot of fun it's a big
stupid dumb time with cars flying out of
airplanes and using parachutes
explosions and fistfights left and right
the rock flexing his muscles these are
all great things and there's part of me
that has to sit back you know as a
person who likes to analyze film and
realize some films just aren't meant for
that some films are just meant to be
dumb and awesome and the Furious films
are those movies I was really satisfied
with the car chase scenes in particular
James Wan did a really good job of
getting some gritty and more intense
camera angles Justin Lin had a very
sleek look to his movies and in the long
run I think his films were better
directive in this movie in all honesty
now as you guys know the production of
this movie faced a major problem when
Paul Walker tragically passed away
everyone was really saddened by that
myself included everything I've ever
heard about that man was that he was or
the sweetest guys in Hollywood and it's
very sad and I can't really doc this
movie for the fact that there are
aspects of it that do feel very
convoluted there are parts where the
plot seems like it's happening in two
different movies and those plots don't
always come together and mix well and
yes it is unfortunately painfully
obvious when CGI Paul Walker is
around you can just tell and it makes it
a little awkward and that is something
that is unfortunate but is kind of
unavoidable and I can't in good
conscience say too many negative things
about that because yes there are
absolutely parts of this movie where the
plot feels very jumbled and very messy
jason statham as a villain is a
fantastic idea but I do feel that he's
very underutilized in this movie he kind
of just comes in whenever they need him
to he just sort of shows up he comes out
in an elevator and there he is and then
he disappears for a while and there's
this whole plot about fighting this
piece of technology that can locate any
person on the planet it's all over the
place that it's really hard to know what
kind of movie they were making before
that tragedy occurred but as I said I do
think that most fans are going to be
satisfied by this movie it is a fitting
send-off
for Paul Walker's character I do think
they handled that as best they could but
I do have two major issues with this
movie and they have nothing to do with
the production or anything that went on
with it my first being that my favorite
thing that happened in the Fast and
Furious franchise ever was the rock as
Hobbs he made five and six way better
than they could have been he's barely in
this movie and that was a major
disappointment for me he's got a cool
scene in the beginning and then he's
pretty much out of commission for the
entire film and that was really a big
letdown for me because he added so much
adrenaline and so much humor to this
movie and the rock is such a likable
presence as an actor that I wanted more
of him and it was disappointing to see
that he was barely in the movie and my
other issue and my biggest one is
unfortunately the thing I was worried
the most about James Wan's handling of
the hand-to-hand combat scenes
unfortunately he chose to adopt the
hyperactive high frame rate quick cut
editing style of today now there isn't
shaky-cam per se it's just that there's
tons and tons of edits and the high
frame rate of it and the close-up nature
of it make it difficult to tell what's
going on those are my two big
disappointments I'm not going to say
negative things about the convoluted
plot because I'm almost positive that
they had such a hard time making this
movie because it would happen and I
can't in good conscience say something
negative about that nevertheless I think
fans are going to have a really good
time with Furious 7 I was a little
disappointed I did not like it as much
as 5 and 6 but overall it is a fitting
send-off for Walker's character there is
a lot of action it's a little too long
but I am going to say that you should go
out and see Furious 7
if you just want to have a dumb
diverting time at theatres where you
don't care about anything except shoving
popcorn in your mouth and watching dudes
drive fast cars and some pretty badass
chicks too I'm going to give Furious 7 a
B the plots convoluted it's all over the
place but I have to give it to these
filmmakers for sitting down and thinking
up the best way to do this a respectful
way and dealing with that unfortunate
tragedy and the best way they could have
and I got to give my hat's off to those
guys guys if you did see this film let
me know what you thought of it below and
I did recently post my anime review for
kids on the slope directed by Shinichiro
Watanabe of Cowboy Bebop Fame a lot of
people have been requesting that and I
delivered that review yesterday so if
you want to check it out it's on my
channel right now guys thank you so much
as always for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes